you go back to the Advent of the
printing press and you can read old
commentary about what that was going to
do to the world and how it was going to
change the world and it's nearly
identical to the same things a lot of
people on the left are saying about
social media today it's gonna produce uh
you know unbridled amounts of
misinformation the information spreading
too fast there's no way to contain it
it's going to lead to societal downfall
yada yada and the solution of course is
always to limit that information it's
it's to suppress it somehow in order to
maintain whatever the narrative is that
you think is the truth that battle has
been happening forever I think covet is
a great example of how the prevailing
acceptable wisdom has changed over time
I mean what used to be totally off
limits like suggesting that it started
in a lab and this was all the result of
a lab leak where that vaccines weren't
totally effective and people were still
spreading the virus and that sort of
thing that's now acceptable speech on a
lot of platforms when it wasn't a year
ago or two years ago or three years ago
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is a
journalist and the founder and editor of
tangle Isaac Sol welcome to trigonometry
thank you guys for having me on I'm
thrilled to be here it's really good to
have you on thank you so much for coming
on uh before we get into the interview
itself and you've got lots of
interesting things to share with our
audience uh tell everybody who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey that brings you to be
sitting here talking to us oh man uh
well my name is Isaac Saul I am the
founder of Tango which is a non-partisan
politics newsletter where we tackle one
big you know controversial debate every
day in the news and summarize the best
arguments we can find from the right and
the left across the political Spectrum
on that argument so you know I I kind of
say there are two Genesis stories for me
as to how ended up in this seat talking
to you guys the first one is that I grew
up in a really divided politically
divided County in Pennsylvania just
outside Philadelphia called Bucks County
where I had a lot of friends and family
who were on opposite sides of the
political Spectrum so I have a lot of
loved ones who do not agree about
politics and that was kind of the
environment that I grew up in with a lot
of arguing and a lot of fights and I
think increasingly you know from my time
in high school when I started really
paying attention to politics to to where
I am now those fights have gotten more
bitter and more divisive which I think a
lot of people recognize and then my
second Genesis story is that I'm a
political journalist by trade I went to
a journalism school and got a job in the
media world my first job ever was at the
Huffington Post which as you probably
know is a very left-wing liberal media
outlet and as I like to say I did not
take my job there because I was a
bleeding heart lib I I took the job
there because I applied 40 other places
and they were the only ones that gave me
a job
um and it's it's not hard to it's not
easy to get a job with a journalism
degree these days so I kind of got to
look at how the sausage was made really
early on for you know a more partisan
media Outlet as my first job and I also
learned what it meant to get tagged in
the media space uh when I left the
Huffington Post I was immediately you
know labeled as a liberal because I had
bylines at Huffington Post and anybody
who could do a Google search pretty
quickly dismissed anything I wrote as
being kind of partisan hackery if they
were a conservative because they could
find out that my first job is at
Huffington Post and they assumed a bunch
of things because of that and so I
learned pretty quickly that our
information system was really divided so
I had an inkling of an idea just to
start tangle really early on in my
journalism career I I helped start and
build a media company with Ashton
Kutcher the actor and venture capitalist
and was there for many years for about
seven years I worked there and led a
politics team there and they went
through an acquisition and sort of
pivoted to video and did all that stuff
that's happening in the media space and
so I kind of built an exit ramp for
myself because I wanted to stay on the
politics beat I wanted to keep writing
and I built tangle as a response to that
and a response to many of the really I
think Insidious forces in the media
space right now that are helping to
contribute to our political divides and
the spread of bad information and you
know the general celebration of people
being partisan hacks which is not
something I'm a particular fan of yeah
totally well listen before we get into
where we are today and all the crap that
you rightly identify as a big cause of
the many issues we have in the world uh
I I was actually quite curious about the
the back story when were you what year
years were you at The Huffington Post
approximately yeah so I I graduated
college in 2013 I'm 31 years old so I
was at the Huffington Post right after
that I actually straight from college I
went into a Yeshiva a religious school
in Jerusalem in Israel again another
interesting experience I was not raised
religious uh but I didn't know what I
wanted to do what exactly I wanted to
write about and I had a campus Rabbi who
I built a relationship with who was like
hey there's this program in Israel you
can go for six months live in a Yeshiva
it's kind of all expenses paid and
you'll get a writing internship and you
know hopefully you'll see the light and
become an orthodox Jew basically was the
idea uh and I went and it was incredible
I mean it was what maybe to this day the
most intellectually stimulating time of
my life I mean
um I was talk about having your child
your your perceptions challenged at
every corner and your belief system
challenge at every corner as someone who
was ocular being dropped into one of the
most religious spaces in the world I got
a lot of attention from very religious
rabbis who were interested in compelling
me to you know come to their side I had
a lot of really interesting
conversations and I did some traveling
in the Middle East and I wrote a lot and
I was there you know in 2013 spring of
2013 summer and fall of 2013 and I was
writing essays and cover letters home
from Israel applying for jobs in the
United States and so I came home I think
in the uh the winter of 2013 right
around the turn of the year to start
working the Huffington Post and I was
there for about a year before I got I
got poached out of the job so it was the
the Facebook boom The Click bait boom it
was the time when articles were getting
millions of views with click bait
headlines and that kind of stuff yeah
and so I gather from the way you talk
about it that uh you were not
necessarily fully aligned with the with
the prevailing ideology at The
Huffington Post at the time is that fair
yeah I think that's fair I mean I you
know I so tell me what that was like
like I'm curious what that's like going
into us but you know from my observation
The Huffington Post is as you said very
left-leaning and kind of ideologically
pretty uh homogeneous in my experience
so going in there with someone who had
slightly different opinions what was
your experience like yeah so I mean
first of all I think like uh I I want to
be careful and that's a broad brush
everybody who worked there or works
there now because that's what happened
to me and um you know that was really
frustrating for me but I I think
generally the Dynamics that you see in
that kind of environment are you know a
headline gets turned into something a
little bit more Sensational or
misleading or intentionally combative
than what your actual story is and and
what you know what the the essence of a
piece you've written is so you might
write a story about a a you know I don't
know a law around abortion or something
and there are lots of caveats in the
story about how you know this law is
unlikely to be passed and there are all
these guard rails in place that would
prevent it from being you know ruled as
a legal and in front of the Supreme
Court or whatever and that story goes
through the kind of machine and it comes
out on the Huffington Post front page
which is like you know abortion rights
threatened for 150 million women across
the country because they want people to
click on it they want people to read it
they want people to share it uh another
thing I experienced frankly was that you
know a lot of the people who were
working in that Newsroom I think grew up
in more uh Urban and Wealthy areas and I
was kind of coming from a background
that had a lot of class and political
diversity even though it was a
predominantly white part of the country
and so you know I just the kind of
conversations I overheard and the
assumptions I think a lot of people made
about the politics of that moment where
not totally aligned with my view on them
now at the same time there are a lot of
reporters there are not a lot but a
handful I can remember for sure who were
from more rural areas or even more
conservative areas who are working at
The Huffington Post who maybe have
liberal beliefs but I thought had like a
much more well-rounded understanding of
the country so that was the kind of
stuff you you know I would see and it
was clear to me that like you know on
the whole 80 to 90 percent of the people
that work there had Center left to far
left political views and when you know
there are teams of people like that
there's very little dissent in The
Newsroom about what stories to cover how
to frame the stories who your sources
are how you pick headlines all those
things and it kind of snowballs and I
think you know going into the 2016
election we saw the ramifications of
that in the sense that a lot of people
in a lot of news organizations miss the
rise of trump and miss the rise of the
Trump right and we're extremely out of
touch with what was happening in places
across the country
Isaac as you were talking to me and bear
in mind we're from the UK so all media
is very different from yours in many
ways but what you were talking to me
about The Huffington Post and the way
they did things and the ways they
sensationalized headlines
we've got the Tabloid press in this
country I'm thinking hang on but that's
no different to what the Sun or the
mirror all of those or the Daily Star or
all of that it'll do in our country
Francis I would add by the way sorry to
interrupt your first question but I've
written pieces for non-tabloid uh
Publications in this country and it's
the same thing you write what you think
is a sensible Nuance piece and then
someone attaches the most incendiary
possible title that's why I no longer
write for mainstream newspapers
yeah I mean I first of all I I don't
think it's at all exclusive to the
Huffington Post obviously I mean I I
think it's um it's something that
happens across the media space I mean I
I'm pretty familiar with the the
ecosystem you guys are operating in I
read a lot of uh British papers I mean
obviously the sun is motivated by the
same things that the Huffington Post is
which is they need traffic because if
they get traffic they get revenue on
their ads I mean it's one of the sort of
fundamental tensions that news
organizations have is that they're
trying to tell stories and give balance
informative information to people but
oftentimes that's less entertaining and
less engaging and less enticing than the
really sort of crazy more incendiary
things that are out there one of the
things that I did when I started tangle
as as a means of combating that was that
I set out to build our entire Revenue
stream based on subscription Revenue
which I think you know so if you are
advertising yourself as a media
organization that's presenting balance
and nuance and all these things and then
readers come in to check out what you're
doing and they get that then they're
going to give you money and that's a
really good incentive you know on the
publishing side to stay true to your
mission stay true to your goal if you're
the Huffington Post and you know your
your goal is to inform the public but
the incentives or that in order to keep
everybody on staff you have to get a
million page views a week then you're
gonna have to do things to hit those
goals which is a really big Challenge
and I don't envy the position that a lot
of those media Outlets are in I mean you
click on a Daily Mail article these days
and you know you get absolutely hammered
with 20 different pop-up ads and videos
and all this stuff and the headlines
crazy and it makes you want to click in
and you know I'm sure there are a lot of
writers and reporters there that wish it
wasn't like that but that's just kind of
how you survive in the in the industry
right now
to put Devil's Advocate position to you
Isaac but isn't that the Trap you're in
and that we're all in in a way because
we have subscribers we let's be we know
what our audience likes we know what our
audience dislikes isn't that the kind of
path that we all have to tread in a way
yeah 100 I mean look I I think
um one of the things that I think is
actually really worrisome about the The
Independent Media space so you know I
know you guys have a sub stack I started
out on sub stack uh you know a lot of
the writers who I read and follow on sub
stack are what I would call kind of
heterodox writers who who are offering
sort of alternative non-mainstream views
on really important issues and the
challenge is that that is is sort of a
bubble and an ideology of its own if if
what you're providing to your readership
is a counter narrative if if the only
goal that you're trying to do is is to
sort of offer something that's kind of
heterodox or different and feed them
what they want and give them what they
want then you're motivated to to look
for that all the time in the same way a
lefty or a righty reporter might be
motivated to look for something that
affirms their beliefs so you know I
think a really good example of that was
actually the war in Ukraine you could go
back and read a lot of the top political
and international writers who are on
platforms like sub stack or independent
writers and a month before Putin invaded
Ukraine they were all saying that it
wasn't going to happen that it was just
saber rattling and the New York Times
And The Washington Post and the Wall
Street Journal and the CIA and all these
all these you know deep State entities
were sort of just fear-mongering
basically and it turned out that the
mainstream narrative was actually right
that you know a lot of the reporting and
the sourcing that was coming from those
Outlets which trust me have gotten tons
of stuff wrong was correct and in
retrospect it was pretty obvious I mean
he put hundreds of thousands of troops
on the border and said he was going to
invade I mean it wasn't a big secret but
we we at the time you know even I bought
into a lot of that kind of heterodox
thinking and I think a lot of people
missed it there so
um yeah you have to be careful I mean
from my perspective uh I I think there's
less pressure in the space that we're in
but absolutely I mean there are the fire
breathers who are independent writers
who I think are motivated you know they
know their audience loves it when they
just absolutely torch the New York Times
or the left or whatever like the crazy
progressives out there and so they're
they're motivated to do that kind of
writing and I do think that's that's a
dangerous trap and you know there are
people who talk about that
um but the forces of that on an
individual to me are are less pernicious
than the institutional pressure that you
get and the threat of losing your job
that you get when you work at one of
these major media Outlets
I said do you think part of the problem
is is because of social media we amplify
the most divisive voices the most
outrageous takes so then we see people
journalists on the left like who work
for you we all know the type of
Publications producing just ridiculous
nonsense and we got this is a leftist
journalist when the actual truth is
there's lots of journalists who lean
left who are left who are actually very
good very principled and the same with
the right so what we have in in many
ways are these two Straw Men Who we see
as left journalists and right
journalists but actually they're not
credible these all these Publications
that we're talking about yeah I mean so
I think one of the most common tactics
that I see in our our kind of modern
political Warfare that happens is the
mainstreaming of idiots you know I mean
it's the idea is pick out the person on
the other side who is saying the most
asinine crazy
um you know derisive combative things
about a certain political group and then
Elevate them and and make it seem as if
this person is the mainstream so you
know a good example is somebody like
Marjorie Taylor green I mean she
whatever had all these crazy beliefs
that she posted about on Facebook about
you know Jewish space lasers and all
this stuff and she's one Republican you
know conservative in the House of
Representatives in the United States
which is probably going to have about
222 Republicans in it in this upcoming
Congress and she's a household name now
I mean she every liberal who's
politically engaged knows who who she is
and they can probably name less than 10
other Republicans in the House of
Representatives why is that it's because
a lot of people on the left Elevate her
and try to make her symbolic of what the
modern day Republican party is and maybe
there are certain issues where she is
representative of the Republican party
today but on the whole I think she's you
know she's pretty fringe she's pretty
far out there she's pretty far right yet
if you ask your standard Democrat in the
U.S to imagine a republican today and
ask you ask them to describe to you what
their beliefs are they're going to
describe somebody like Marjorie Taylor
green and I think that's because of the
effectiveness of that kind of political
Warfare and the same goes for you know
conservatives on the right and and what
they do at the left I mean Alexandria
ocasio-cortez widely considered one of
the most far left Progressive Democrats
in the house she's also the most famous
and and that's because the right and
conservative media have intentionally
made her the most famous to sort of say
this is the modern day Democratic party
and if you're scared of this if you
don't like this then you should vote for
Republicans so you know one of the
things I try and do in my work is offer
up people who aren't that Fringe who
aren't that far right I mean you know or
far left I I in our newsletters we do
include those Fringe opinions but
they're maybe one of you know seven or
eight opinions that you're gonna see
that way you understand you know here's
the spectrum of what the thought is on
this side of the aisle so you don't
leave feeling like everybody on the left
is AOC and everybody on the rights
Marjorie Taylor green
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
well that makes a lot of sense but I
suppose I was thinking when we were
talking about the Daily Mail and the Sun
and tabloids and other Publications on
The Huffington Post and whatever
isn't this one of those things where
it's like maybe you like to go to an
expensive restaurant but quite a lot of
people are quite happy to eat at
McDonald's you know I I enjoy a
McDonald's once a year but I generally
don't go to that sort of place but but
every time I drive past the McDonald's
it's full of people right so is this is
it really true that a lot of people want
to have this
non-partisan long form you know sensible
multi-faceted Nuance conversation I mean
it's what we try to do on trigonometry
and we have an audience but every time I
turn on YouTube I'm confronted with the
fact that you know a hot right-wing girl
calling someone on the left a [ __ ] or a
shill or whatever is going to get a
million views when we do a sensible
interview with someone like you you
might get you know 50 000 views or ten
thousand views might get a hundred
thousand views but it's not going to get
a million views because most people want
a McDonald's isn't that true yeah for
sure I mean look there's a there are a
few kind of uphill battles I think that
uh people in Aerospace Are Climbing
because I do sort of think you guys are
doing work that is you know similar to
mine which is first of all everybody's
going to click on the headline about you
know the Dozen kids dying in a bus crash
before they click on a headline about
you know a political political party
solving a Water Crisis and you know some
City and in Houston or whatever I mean
that that is the reality of the
challenge that we're at I've I've worked
at news organizations that produce
quote-unquote good news feel good
content
um or Solutions journalism journalism
about people who are solving things
rather than people who are creating
problems and it is hard it is hard to
get people to engage with that stuff uh
I do think there are ways to do it
though and I think there are ways to
raise the interest level I mean when I'm
pitching tangle to people and trying to
get them to sign up and give our
newsletter a shot I I changed the way I
talk about it honestly depending on the
kind of person I'm talking to and what
their political worldview is and and
both pitches are really honest but I
also know that one's going to be more
effective than the other so you know if
I'm talking to a conservative right-wing
Trumper type I'm gonna say look I
started a media Outlet because I agree
the media is broken there's not enough
trust there's too much bias there's not
enough transparency there's no balance
so so I built something to try and solve
that I got tired of talking about what
the problem is give it a shot if you
don't see your views represented if you
don't think it's fair you don't have to
read it but I think if you try it you'll
like it and that's a really appealing
pitch to them because we meet on the
fact that yeah the media ecosystem is
broken and these incentives are wrong
and there are a lot of journalists out
there who aren't being fair if I'm
talking to a liberal uh you know it's
more like if you still don't understand
why Trump was elected in 2016 and almost
got reelected in 2020 or why he's still
the most popular politician in the
Republican party you should get out of
your news bubble you're in an
information Bible if you don't
understand that yet and the answer isn't
racism okay it's it's something much
more it's something much broader and and
more important and more I guess I would
say complex than that and that is a good
way to get people like okay maybe I do
have more to learn about other people in
the United States maybe I am
misunderstanding what a lot of people in
America think or feel and so they'll
come check out Tango to sort of get a
better understanding of the other side
of what's happening in the conservative
space because a lot of conservatives
feel like they're surrounded by liberal
media and a lot of liberals feel like
they have no idea how a conservative
could believe what they believe in the
United States I actually think the true
is same for a lot of the politics in
your country and I think you know
something like what I'm doing would be
really effective and draw a big audience
there and you know to your point it's
it's not easy to win people over on the
the Nuance of things but I do think
there is a ground swell and a kind of
Grassroots
Uprising against the way things are
right now that's happening and you know
you guys having 300 000 YouTube
subscribers is part of that we have 365
mate we've worked hard 365
thousand YouTube subscribers I mean that
that is proof of it uh I've seen your
channel I've watched your videos you
guys have really uh long form and
oftentimes controversial conversations
that I think regardless of where people
were from they would feel uncomfortable
in certain moments yet they're coming
back and they're watching uh I think
that's proof of it tangle has over 50
000 people on our mailing list I think
that's proof of it I I think the the
kind of the swell of Independent Media
that we're seeing right now that's
challenging a lot of the traditional
media Outlets is proof of it so yeah
it's not easy you're we're definitely
competing with one hand tied behind our
backs but uh because you know human
nature wants the kind of sensationalist
stuff that reaffirms our World Views but
I do think there are more and more
people who are increasingly interested
in this kind of content
Isaac I was listening uh to an interview
you did
um as part of my research and you said
something really fascinating you said
that in 2014 you could see the creation
and the rise of echo Chambers way before
Trump way before brexit way before any
of that why was that
a big reason why was because of the
community I grew up in you know like I I
was back then you know it's crazy to
think about now because Facebook's kind
of a ghost town at least for me but that
was where so much political discourse
was happening you know the the hundreds
of comments on you know some high school
teachers Facebook status or whatever I
mean it was like people were debating
fighting tooth and nail about politics
on platforms like Facebook and a little
bit of Twitter but mostly Facebook and I
saw I mean the the post the kind of news
and information that people were posting
on Facebook back then from my friends
who were on the left and my friends who
are on the right well it wasn't like two
articles that were varying opinions on
the same news event it was they were
talking about totally different news
events or they were talking about the
same news event but had a totally
different underlying set of facts that
they they were believing in that they
were you know talking about in the
comments and fighting over and it was
like the old days where we would be
throwing Links at each other and bombing
Facebook statuses with you know
long-form posts about why somebody was
wrong and having all the sources cited
at the bottom and you could see it plain
as day I mean it was just like people
were getting their information from two
different sources it wasn't like these
guys were both reading a New York Times
article and had a disagreement about the
language that was being used it was like
one side was pulling something from a
really obscure conservative blog with
you know some truths and some fictions
and the other side was pulling something
from a really obscure liberal blog with
some truths and some fictions and they
were going to battle with that kind of
information and so I I was I was worried
back then that so many people who I knew
personally were sort of projecting this
really combative personality online and
we're clearly immersed in in these like
really politically affirming information
ecosystems and you know between 2014 and
now there have been tons of studies
about this about you know how that Echo
chamber increases partisanship
um how oftentimes even trying to break
the echo chamber actually also increases
partisanship which is a really
interesting phenomenon so people who
post more politically on Facebook are
also now more likely to run into you
know the the dissenter the person
dropping their comments but because of
the way people interact on Facebook
because it's so combative it actually
doesn't bring you know it doesn't
moderate their views it makes them dig
their heels in more because they're
fighting off enemies left and right
online so there's a lot of really really
troubling stuff that I think we've seen
in that space But yeah I mean it was it
was just my friends and family members
and that kind of anecdotal thing that I
was seeing being that I imagined was you
know not unique to me and it turned out
that it wasn't that's really interesting
sorry no no you go I was I was going to
ask her on that front because the I
suppose the the way that their code
Chambers would have been in 2014 it just
seems to me that it's on a whole
different level now uh and you mentioned
the war in Ukraine we were actually one
of the few people in the alt media space
who did say it was going to happen and
and kind of broke down why it happened
immediately afterwards for people who
hadn't been following
um but um you know you know the war in
Ukraine is a good example because uh I
am absolutely convinced that if Donald
Trump had won the 2020 election and the
Vladimir Putin had still invaded the
entire of the almost the entire of the
right would now be massively in favor of
funding Ukraine and the entire left will
be massively against funding Ukraine uh
I I'm I'm convinced of that because
we've got to a point where it's like the
right used to mock the left for
supporting the current thing my it's the
idea it's this meme online that people
will support anything as long as the
mainstream is telling them to support it
and of course the right A lot of it not
all of it but portions of it have now
got to a position where they oppose
the current thing or without thinking
without analyzing without critical
thought and thanks to the Eco Chambers
and the availability of all sorts of
media now
if you want to build the case for or
against or supporting Ukraine or against
supporting Ukraine or for neutrality or
for not caring about it or for the fact
that it's actually fake news or that it
was you know Jewish conspiracy whatever
there's plenty of you know sub stacks
and YouTube videos and Rumble and
whatever that you can find to make what
is on the surface a legitimate case for
whatever it is that you believe right
yeah yeah I know for sure and so uh I
think there's a couple of things at play
there first of all I think it's what you
just said which is that the media space
is so fractured now and there's so much
out there there's so much information
out there on the internet that it
doesn't really matter you know how
obscure or maybe detached from reality
your Viewpoint is you can probably find
somebody who has published a
well-articulated video or article or a
podcast that's sort of making the case
for you to affirm that so you know
enough Google or Bing or DuckDuckGo
searches and and you're gonna come
across the thing that you want so that's
one two uh you know I I did a really
interesting interview with a guy named
Hiram Lewis who's writing a book called
The the myth of the left and the right
and he makes what I think is maybe the
most compelling case or explanation I
think for our current political moment
which is that there just is no left and
right it's just a total it's an
abstraction where what defines being
left or right has just completely been
upended and changed and moved repeatedly
throughout the course of American and
global history and you know his argument
is basically like we live in political
tribes increasingly in today's society
People's Community are tied closely to
their political worldview and so if your
community is your political tribe then
you're gonna kind of follow what the
tribe does because you want to stay a
part of that Community regardless of if
it violates whatever you're preconceived
you know purported uh I guess
allegiances are and you'll change your
worldview to kind of fit in it's
basically his argument and he and he
makes a really good case for it I mean
the example is that he uses her like you
know when George W bush invaded Iraq uh
and you know launched us into this war
against Terror in the Middle East the
commentary back then was that he was
moving the Republican party to the right
and when Donald Trump took office and
took this isolationist stance that he
was gonna you know pull troops home from
the Middle East the commentary was he
was lurching the party to the right and
it's like okay well what does it mean to
go to the right then it doesn't make any
sense I mean a lot of people Define
conservatives and progressives as
conservatives want to conserve they want
to keep things as they are progressives
are trying to change they're trying to
change what it means to be a woman and
they're trying to change same-sex
marriage and all these things and then
we just have this Roe v Wade case where
you know 80 years of precedent is
upended in a day because conservatives
wanted to change what the current law is
so doing that was considered you know
launching the country to the right it
was considered this very conservative
moment in American history yet they
weren't really conserving anything they
were making a really big change to the
country of which you know the
repercussions I think we just saw in
this election was that voters sort of
um clap back basically so uh you know I
I don't really buy that the left and the
right are actual poles of political
ideologies that were subscribed to I
think there are you know moments in
history where we have vague
understandings of what it means to be
left or what it means to be right big
government little government
um you know big government small
government conserving progressing but
they're always Dynamic and moving and
changing and so sorry to interrupt so
what are the tribes then because I agree
with you completely and I hate using
terms like right and left because
they're inaccurate generalizations
however the raw tribes that clearly are
at loggerheads with each other right now
uh as they always have been frankly
what is the is it you know some people
talk it's
pro-establishment anti-establishment but
I don't imagine a lot of progressives
think of themselves as being pro The
Establishment they think they're radical
uh people who are changing the nature of
society they don't think of themselves
as having control of every institution
as the the right quote unquote would see
them right so so what other tribes how
how are we to to break ourselves down
yeah it's it's a great question I mean I
think I can answer that in terms of
what's happening in the United States I
would have a harder time talking more
broadly about you know global politics
or specifics yeah don't worry we inherit
all your stuff it's all right let's use
technical language here mate you're [ __ ]
yeah I love your [ __ ] and we inject this
straight into eye yeah you guys are
maybe the only ones who uh have crazier
politics than we do right now uh and
you're welcome for that I guess yeah but
we have guns so we're okay yeah right
exactly yeah so
um look I mean I I think fundamentally
the tribes of the Republican and
Democratic party I mean when you talk
about voters I still think it's the
duopoly of the two parties you know one
of the reasons that we see fewer and
fewer Landslide elections is because
party Allegiance is is really strong
among voters and it doesn't matter how
bad a candidate is or how much they're
violating creating you know that
person's political world view if they
have an r or a d against their name
voters are just really likely to vote
for them uh that being said in America I
do think that we basically have what I
would call I mean I I view it as like
four main tribes
um two on each side I think you know on
the right we have the sort of Old Guard
you know you call it the establishment
Republicans some people call it
traditional Republicans uh I'm talking
Mitch McConnell Mitt Romney that sort of
era of Republicans that really talk
about being you know aligned with small
government and you know some some
semblance of bipartisanship tons of
respect for the traditions of the
country constitutionality that kind of
thing uh then I think there's sort of
this new era of right-wing conservatism
that you know existed 20 years ago but I
think has really been elevated and
escalated by Donald Trump which is you
know battling the culture wars it's
stopping the progress have left from
making changes that they view as being
really dangerous to the country it's
really focused on immigration uh it's it
doesn't necessarily matter whether
something is a big government or small
government type policy or whether it's
constitutional or unconstitutional and
like the very traditional sense of the
word it's about winning it's about
making sure that Republicans you know
get off their knees and start fighting
for the country that that they really
believe in and that's kind of like the
attitude of that new right and then I
think on the left there's the you know
the the maybe traditional or
establishment Democrats I would call
them the corporate Democrats which you
know I know is a derisive term but I
think
um a is accurate and B isn't always
necessary doesn't always necessarily
mean that they have you know bad
policies or the wrong policies but this
is sort of like the more Elite donor
class Democratic party that has a lot of
power a lot of influence at Major
institutions corporations colleges those
kinds of things things and they're
interested in some Regard in keeping the
status quo which I think is very
different from the kind of establishment
or the kind of trump right and the
progressive left they they want things
to be stable
um they're fighting for progress but
they're doing it in a very sort of
incremental way and they're really
interested in in doing it you know via
bipartisanship things like that Joe
Biden I think for the most part is a
member of this sort of party Nancy
Pelosi I would definitely put in that
kind of you know Democratic
establishment and then you have the
progressive left and I think those are
sort of like you know maybe closer to
the the Trump right in terms of attitude
and respect for norms and that kind of
thing uh obviously to your point they
get put against each other all of a
sudden you have Progressive lefts like
you know trumpeting FBI talking points
and stuff which makes my head want to
explode but um generally speaking I
think these are people who are like
we've had incremental change forever we
we want real broad changes to the
country now we want to upend the systems
that have produced a lot of inequality
in the country a lot of the problems in
the country and uh you know I think
similar to the kind of trump right the
progressive left is is interested in
winning they feel like you know they've
had many years of being dismissed or
ignored and they are sort of the
activist type who are like we're gonna
do whatever it takes to win we're gonna
play dirty fight hard all these things
and
um try and make the real broad overhaul
to the country systems that they want to
see so to me those are like the four
tribes that we have in in our politics
today and they're all kind of at war
with each other
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably run near like the
sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only Lee baroness
Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
do you think that this fragmentation of
society has been exacerbated by the fact
that no one really trusts the mainstream
media anymore not left not right because
we've been let down and been betrayed so
many times by them whatever institution
it is so as a result of that a distrust
Creeps in which means also people are
likely to think in a more conspiratorial
manner like whenever I think about
progressivism to me it's quite a
conspiratorial way of thinking there's
this systemic thing in place that is
keeping certain people down and that
means certain people can't progress and
if you think about the rights especially
the sort of the Trump right they believe
that as well just in a different form
yeah no I mean look the uh obviously
from my position the Trust in Media is
one of the core issues I mean
foundational to my goal with tangle like
the very essence of it is that I'm
trying to create a media outlet that
where we see equal levels of trust from
our conservative readers and our liberal
readers I think that is one of like the
only real true signs that you're
producing content that is representing a
really diverse and holistic set of views
so I mean there's no doubt I I think
it's the combination of a the mistrust
and the fact that there have been so
many big media blunders you know in the
last 20 30 years I think it's also be
that there's now so many alternatives to
you know some of the stuff we've been
talking about it's that like you don't
have to just get the New York Times or
the Washington Post or the Wall Street
Journal the New York Post or whatever to
your front doorstep every day you can go
out and find stuff in you know a few
clicks by typing a few words in on an
internet search browser and you're going
to get presented with a lot of different
alternative media a lot of different
options for for news to consume but yeah
I mean you look at the numbers the pure
polling of it in terms of you know trust
in uh in the media and the the only the
only things that Americans trust less
and I think this is probably true of a
lot of people in Europe is their current
government I mean it's
um that that's pretty much it it's
Congress gets lower approval ratings and
right right next to them is a lot of the
media that's out there and so you know I
think there's two parts of that one is a
lot of media is going to challenge your
world view and and when your world use
challenge that might make you upset it
might make you you know sometimes the
New York Times publishes an article that
is a really great piece of reporting
that sheds some light on some truth but
conservatives don't like the truth that
it sheds light on so they hate the New
York Times more and they trust the New
York Times less so it's a tough
conundrum to to sort of navigate but
um it's a big problem because if we all
can't agree on the basic set of facts
and a story then we're not really going
to get anywhere in terms of you know
moderating our views or even
understanding what the other side thinks
and this brings us on to an issue that
you I think you'll I've read a few
things that you've you've written about
this uh this brings us onto the issue of
misinformation
um and just very briefly do you think
you know in percentage terms there is
more misinformation now than there has
ever been or is it more a case of you
know
10 years ago the New York Times could
publish a piece that wasn't true and
nobody would know or most people
wouldn't know and now if they do that
well there are going to be people on
subtype on YouTube and whatever
challenging it so we're more aware of
the fact that what we're being told
isn't quite true yeah I I think it is
that there's just more awareness of it I
mean I think misinformation is a problem
but I do not think it's a it's it's the
kind of problem especially a lot of
people on the left believe that it is uh
Jacob well because first of all it's
something we've been battling forever
um you know I mean you go back to the
Advent of the printing press and you can
read old commentary about what that was
going to do to the world and how it was
going to change the world and it's
nearly identical to the same things a
lot of people on the left are saying
about social media today it's gonna
produce uh you know unbridled amounts of
misinformation the information spreading
too fast there's no way to contain it
it's going to lead to societal downfall
yada yada and the solution of course is
always to limit that information it's
it's to suppress it somehow in order to
maintain whatever the narrative is that
you think is the truth uh Etc that
battle has been happening forever I mean
it's happened over and over and over
throughout history
um Jacob and changa wrote a great book
about the history of free speech that
touches on a lot of this stuff and uh
that that has informed a lot of my
writing about it is just this idea that
you know our the misinformation threat
today seems so important and so scary
and it's so big that the only solution
is you know we need the government to
regulate what gets posted on Facebook or
Twitter which to me is totally insane
um so you know that that's that's kind
of the tension that I see in terms of
the historical precedent being there and
us feeling like we're really important
in living everything that's happening to
us in modern times has to be this major
historical unprecedented event that I I
just don't think it is right now well I
will say one thing I mean the printing
press did cause about two centuries of
religion so so it wasn't an uneventful
period of time in human history and and
I don't think that there will be
um I don't think there will be a periods
of you know total stability as the
Advent of social media continues to grow
I mean obviously we've seen it in the
United States just in the last few years
that I think there's you know more
political violence and unrest than we've
seen in a few decades but
um I also don't think anybody would look
back on the Advent of the printing press
and say that you know what came of that
and the information the way that we were
able to share information educate people
wasn't worth it in terms of of The
Upside so it's a it's a really difficult
thing you know it's not it's not a black
and white issue but yeah you raise a
good point that it's it's not a
guarantee that things are going to go
smoothly that's for sure
you know and we talk about the age of
misinformation but if you look at a
figure for instance like Alex Jones I
know it's a classic figure to say you
look at the Sandy Hook case the fact
that he had this huge platform could
spread the most horrendous
misinformation which then had dire
consequences in the in in the real world
surely that is quite unprecedented isn't
it the fact that it's this one guy who's
then able to cause all this amount of
Destruction and disruption I should say
yeah I mean I I I guess I haven't really
considered how that scale would
translate historically I mean I'm sure
that there are some figures we could
find you know who handed out pamphlets
or spread you know certain religious
texts or some of the first people who
were dominant in the radio era that
maybe spread more misinformation or
spread similarly dangerous
disinformation
um I think one of the critical things
about Alex Jones is that you know he he
did things him specifically uh he did
things in a way that were violating you
know certain terms of service that some
of the platforms he was on had which led
to the repercussions that he's faced now
so you know I we're making an agreement
I think a societal agreement that we're
gonna have some Alex Jones is and we're
gonna have to figure out how to navigate
them but the trade-off for that is that
you know when there's protests in China
like we're seeing right now there's a
way for somebody to upload a video
that's you know shedding a light on the
repression of political dissent in 10
seconds on Tick Tock which would have
been impossible 30 years ago and we
wouldn't have any idea what was
happening on the ground there right now
and and that's really good to me so
um you know it's it's not it's it's not
a it's not an eye for an eye in terms of
that trade-off and I think there's going
to be upsides and downsides but on the
whole I think you know what we've seen
throughout history is that when when
Free Speech thrives Society is better
off even if it gets a little rocky at
times
I mean so so what do we do with figures
like this what do we do with figures who
have a huge platform
put out conspiracy theories
misinformation because the other flip
side of the coin is and we all remember
during covid when we were all affected
by this when people were challenging
certain narratives they lost their
Channel they had strikes put against and
they were demonetized they were Shadow
banned
he's just talking about us yeah
I've been silenced Isaac you you're
joking but we do actually have there was
a video that we did with the journalists
in the UK called Peter Hitchens about
his criticism of lockdowns and we caught
YouTube Shadow Banning it we literally
have a video on our Channel which shows
that it was Shadow band so this was this
isn't conspiracy this was happening a
hundred percent yeah so I I the the I
mean that is my argument you know I and
I know this is like maybe it offers up a
little bit of my political worldview and
where I come from but
um my personal opinion is a that D
platforming the vast majority of the
times is uh has the opposite effect of
of what's intended and B that the the
net sum of you know allowing the sort of
Shadow Banning the removal of like these
dissenting opinions is actually bad for
society I mean you know to your point I
think covet is a great example of how
the prevailing acceptable wisdom them
has changed over time I mean what used
to be totally off limits like suggesting
that it started in a lab and this was
all the result of a lab leak or that
vaccines weren't totally effective and
people were still spreading the virus
and that sort of thing that's now
acceptable speech on a lot of platforms
when it wasn't a year ago or two years
ago or three years ago and I understand
the rationale for that I understand the
I think you know maybe my Nuance
perspective is the the reason that those
platforms felt that pressure to remove
that kind of content I think actually
came from a good place they they were
being told by certain you know medical
institutions that this was
disinformation the vaccines worked it
didn't come from a lab and if you
allowed this information to spread on
your platform a bunch of people were
gonna die and if you're somebody making
you know content moderation decisions
being told that what you're allowing is
going to lead to thousands or millions
of people dying is probably a really
scary thing so I don't envy the position
they were in I think they made the wrong
choice in a lot of cases I think that's
been proven out by what's happened you
know up to today uh in terms of what to
do with people like this look I mean
in a lot of ways I think it often Works
itself out I you know you click onto
something Alex Jones tweets or used to
tweet when he was allowed on the
platform and the first hundred responses
are people mocking him for being crazy
you know they're or they're fact
checking him or they're quote cheating
him and dunking on him and getting a ton
of traction doing that yada yada I mean
that all that stuff I think is effective
in a lot of ways at sort of limiting the
I guess the the acceptability of a
character like him and I think a lot of
that stuff happens organically on these
platforms at the same time platforms are
allowed to make rules they're private
companies if people violate those rules
they're allowed to kick them off the
platforms my issue with a lot of the
stuff Twitter and YouTube has done is
that they don't apply those standards
evenly so if you're going to have a
standard apply it and and use it uh in
the case of Alex Jones you know I don't
think de-platforming him actually worked
I think there's you know a tremendous
amount of for this his you know his
audience has grown faster than ever over
the last few years you know you look at
all these really I guess you know scary
political events that people point to as
the result of characters like Alex Jones
like January 6th Alex Jones was at
January 6 with a megaphone telling a
crowd what to do you know two years
after he'd been banned from some of
these platforms so did it really work
was he was he really made this
ineffective character no he just went to
this dark corner of the internet where
people were consuming his content
without seeing any dissent without being
engaged by any people who thought that
Alex Jones was a whack job and so this
community you know around him becomes
even more insular and probably more
extreme in the long term I think one of
the only real successful D platformings
that I've witnessed or remembered was
Milo yiannopoulos who you know basically
I think disappeared after he was
de-platformed and even him we're now
seeing him pop his head back up I mean
he's like on Tim pool's podcast with
Nick Fuentes and Kanye and all of a
sudden he's kind of back in the mix so
who knows maybe he become somebody
but yeah yeah yeah it was uh you know I
I mean it was a in some ways it was
great I mean that podcast is a perfect
example of why we should allow these
people to to come out into the daylight
I I agree completely I just wrote a
whole sub stack piece saying that very
same thing even though a big part of me
kind of winced when I saw the guest
lineup totally uh it's a strong flavor
you're right yeah yeah I mean I'm I'm
look I'm I'm I'm a Jew who is
semi-observant and deeply connected to
the Jewish community so obviously the
stuff with Kanye whose music I love and
Nick Fuentes who is you know just a
total [ __ ] I mean it's it's scary to
see people like that go on a big YouTube
show but what Tim Poole did is exactly
why we should allow it because he made
he made it so obvious that Kanye is
incapable of hearing an opinion that he
doesn't agree with and can't even make
the case for himself and they just look
like a bunch of weasels you know and and
I watched it and was like this is great
this is why if you allow these people on
these platforms and you handle it in the
right way it actually exposes a real
deep truth about them which is often
that they're deeply insecure and don't
really have any clue what they're
talking about which I think is good for
society as a whole to show that to
people in Mass
couldn't agree more well on that happen
you know Isaac it's been an absolute
pleasure speaking with you we're going
to ask you a couple of questions from
our supporters that only they will get
to see the answers to on locals uh but
for now we've got one final question for
you which is the same as it always is
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
God that is uh it's such a difficult
question
um you know it's funny I guess the first
thing that comes to my mind is I was at
a conference last couple weeks ago and I
saw this really fascinating uh
presentation on sustainable housing and
not in like the super woo-woo greens you
know kind of very Progressive liberal
sense but in this very like Innovative
sense of building homes that were
totally self-sustainable with you know
grass growing on their roofs and
vertical Farms inside and all these
really cool mechanisms for capturing
heat or keeping the house cool and uh
yeah I think there's like a ton of
really interesting Solutions out there
to some of the big problems we have in
terms of energy which I'm sure you guys
are feeling right now and even climate
change that all kind of work together
that uh you know it's there's a lot of
Doomsday stuff and a lot of attachment
to to Solutions we've had for years like
you know wind and solar and
um then there's all these really
Innovative people I think who are like
50 years into the future already who I
don't think we give enough attention to
so go look up some of that stuff that's
what I would say it's pretty cool it
gives it gives me Faith in uh the
capacity for Innovation and not
government to solve a lot of our really
big problems
perfect and of course do check out
tangle as well for that non-partisan uh
take on all things political and news uh
Isaac thank you so much for coming on
it's been a pleasure and thank you guys
for watching and listening we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or also all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys see you soon
on locals
what are some news stories you'd want to
look into but can't or don't have the
time to and that might be too
problematic or too dangerous to explore
in the current part as an era
foreign
[Music]